hi everyone alex gent here so today's
video we're going to be looking at
transferring the staff from a ford's
figure eight
to a backwards figure eight both at the
top and at the bottom
if you're unsure how to do a figure
eight both forwards and backwards on
both the left and right hand side
i suggest going to see my previous video
which i'll link either above or in the
description below
if you're okay with that though let's
get into it
[Music]
so there's so many different types of
hand transfers that we can do in this
video i'm going to be showing you one of
the basic ones i'll also be giving you
some ideas and concepts to play with
and focus more on principles than
actually specific techniques
so the stuff that i'm using today has
got a nice marker in the middle showing
us where the center point is this is
really important to know
when we're gripping it if i'm gripping
either side i could have both palms
facing down i could have one up one down
i could have both up or i could have the
opposite of one up and one down
this also applies when my arms are
crossed i could have one or four one
down
i could have both up and down this could
be either
either hand on top or i could have it
the opposite way around with both hands
palms facing up so you have all these
different permutations
the other thing to consider is that when
you're gripping the stuff and you're
doing a figure eight
are you gripping it just below the
center point
in which case this side is the short
side
and the end if you like the thumb side
my thumb was pointing out
is the the long side so if i was doing a
forward figure eight you can see the
long side
is the one that's leading and then if i
was to do a backwards figure eight
it'd be the short side that's leading in
the spin
i could also grab from the top side just
above the center point
so when i do a forwards figure eight
it's the short side that's leading
or if i'm going in a backwards figure
eight it's the long side that's lady
so the reason this is relevant is
because depending on where my hand
placement is depends on the type of hand
transfer i do
so for example if i was to do a figure
eight here
with the back end are holding the back
end of the staff
rather than the front end here
as i transfer to the other hand if i
just sweep down
into this position notice depending on
where i've got this hand it could be
underneath or it could be on top
this hand here is facing facing down
if i was to have it palm up that means
the
this end of the staff crosses over in
which case then i need to receive it
into a cross grip
like this if however i was to grab
rather than behind the center point
above
so then i'd have the longer end trailing
behind in a forward figure eight
and then i was to change over i could
either receive it with my hands crossed
or if i was to turn it over see now my
palm
is facing up and this hand could be in
any of these permutations
and i could transfer here and then
continue into a backwards figure
probably the most basic and practical
way to receive the stuff is to have one
palm facing down and one palm facing up
so if i stick my thumbs out both thumbs
are facing the same direction
that could be in that position or it
could be in this position here
personally this type of grip i think has
more of a martial application which i'll
cover in a later video
so before i explain how we go from force
to backwards we'll cover the pendulum
swing
just from side to side just doing this
basic hand transfer
from one hand to the other so the way we
can do this if we hold the staff out
and the short side is behind
as we swing down here i receive it
with my palm facing up
this palms facing down let's swap it
over
my hands cross over and then i take it
to the opposite side
you'll notice here i'm grabbing above
the center point so in one hand it's
going to be above the center point
as i change it back over here stop in
the middle
you see now i'm grabbing below the
center point
so one side above the center point
the other side below the center pump
we can also then change this over
so now it's the opposite so as i swing
this out
you see here now i'm below the center
point on my left hand side
as i bring it to the other side i'm now
above the center point on my opposite
side
then from here you can just switch
whichever grip
you want just by sliding your hands over
so if we were to hold in the center of
the staff the same hand transfer could
be used
as i swing my hands down
instead of gripping at the side i let my
hand slide over the other hand
and it kind of palms over from one side
to the other
and it just creates a smooth hand
transfer from side to side
the reason i like this type of hand
transfer is because it can be applied
with other things
such as clubs
so the same concept applies when we're
changing above our head if i take this
grip
and take it above my head the same thing
applies if i
open out i change into this grip
let it turn over you can see the same
idea applies if it's above my head
if i let this continue i can continue
the momentum all the way around so it
completes a circle
so i'm changing at the bottom and
changing at the top as well
it's using that same hand transfer the
same
idea of transferring like this i use it
at the top
transfer at the top transfer other one
and i'm actually transitioning through a
figure eight
here so at any point i could stop
so for example here i could stop and go
into a ford's figure eight
or if i continue it round i could stop
here
and continue with the backless figure
right
obviously we can do this both directions
so i could do the forwards figure eight
on this side and then continue
down and take it up to the top
so now on my right hand side i'm doing a
backwards figure right there
the other way to understand how the
forwards and backwards figure eight fit
together
is if you look at where the transition
happens
on the front plane here the circle that
i'm creating here
actually becomes the backward circle
on the other side the same for the
backward circle
as i create this large circle here
if i was to transition here i'm going
into a forward
figure right there but instead of just
remaining
with the same using the same hand
i actually transition into the other
hand
so once you understand the principles of
how hand transfers work you could try
other ideas such as having both palms
facing
upwards and you can do the same thing
changing at the top like this
and changing at the bottom you could
also try
from side to side so changing at the
sides
and then alternating from side to side
and again all these linked together
we could then link it to the top hand
transfer
and then to the side transfer
okay there's some ideas to play with
there i hope you found it interesting
if you've got any questions leave them
in the comments below i'm going to
continue to look at figure eight
movements in the next video
this time introducing body movement and
being able to turn from side to side
and then transition from hand to hand
above and below
and then just basically just linking
everything together
if you're enjoying these videos please
remember to give it a like share and
subscribe as this helps the channel grow
until next time take care and i will see
you soon
you